while we're interrupting that edition of
the stream to bring you some breaking
news I will bring you live footage now
from the Green Zone in Baghdad swear we
understand hundreds of mourners have
entered the green zone or are attempting
to storm the US Embassy in Baghdad now
this follows those deadly air strikes on
the Shia armed group Hezbollah begin
brigades that those airstrikes happening
in the last 48 hours at least 27 people
were killed and those funerals are
taking place today now al Jazeera sumona
14 is in Baghdad she's in the Green Zone
where those protests are taking place as
sulmona
just bring us up to date what's
happening where you are well hundreds
perhaps even thousands of people have
entered the green zone and are marching
towards the embassy I'm currently at the
outer gate of the US Embassy which is
located perhaps three 300 or 400 metres
away from the actual entrance and this
entire funeral procession consisting
mostly of PMS members and their
followers have basically entered through
this gate without any resistance
whatsoever with the by the Iraqi
security forces that are supposed to
guard the green zone which means that
basically the Iraqi government is
supporting this March and possibly also
the messages that they're trying to pass
they're chanting
anti-american slogans they're basically
calling on the u.s. to withdraw from
Iraq and they say that they will achieve
that through military or through
political means but for now this entire
procession has basically reached our US
embassy this is quite a significant
development we've seen in the past
perhaps one occasion where
anti-government protesters were able to
enter the Green Zone but I don't believe
we have seen such a large number of
people come this close to the US Embassy
so it remains to be seen how the
authorities will react and more
importantly
how the US will react emits a sum on how
close are you to the u.s. embassy can
you see any kind of confrontation there
I mean how close are the protestors
getting to that embassy building which
one must assume is very heavily defended
yes I'm currently around 300 meters away
from the actual building I can see it I
can see the masses marching towards it
so far there is no indication that there
are armed confrontations cannot hear any
kind of gunfire or anything like that
people are passing by chanting anti us
slogans and they're being allowed to go
through and as far as I can see it seems
that they have basically reached the
embassy by now and that is their aim the
question remains what will happen once
they settle down there will the u.s. try
to push them back will it respond in any
manner and how long will they stay there
and some will give us that for viewers
who perhaps not so familiar with the
Iraqi capital are not familiar with the
green zone and just talk us more talk to
us more about at what the green zone is
and why it's so significant that this
large number of protesters were able to
to walk to descend on what is normally a
very fortified area so the green zone
houses a number of government
institutions it also has several
embassies including the US embassies US
embassy and also the United Nations and
it was temporarily opened up to the
public before anti-government protests
began since then it has been closed down
again and it's impossible to actually
enter this fortified zone without having
a special badge but of course of course
not being enforced at the moment because
these huge masses of people were entered
without any sort of effort to try to
prevent them and it's really quite
remarkable and it's a sign that the
government is standing behind the PMF if
the government is supporting this March
as well as the message that they're
trying to pass
and this comes at a time of significant
turmoil in Baghdad because not just in
Baghdad in Iraq on the whole the the
last few weeks and months have been
marked by significant amounts of protest
and the government itself is in quite a
tricky spot he just talked us through
some of the the recent events and how do
you think this march on the the u.s.
embassy please into all of that
[Music]
well this March and basically the u.s.
strikes they further complicate an
already very precarious situation in
Europe the government has been besieged
after three months of anti-government
protests it is weekend
it is divided and this kind of protest
against US presidents only adds to what
is already an extremely complicated
situation now it's very difficult to say
what these recent rocket attacks against
faced with where the u.s. is stationed
and the response by the u.s. to target
the PMF is all related to the protests
of course there have been a lot of
rumors here in Iraq unconfirmed rumors
that the u.s. is somehow encouraging
these notice for some hardline but there
is no evidence whatsoever for that but
it is something that could have prompted
some of these armed groups to launch
attacks against these bases in the first
place now question what can the Iraqi
government usually do based on the
statements that we have seen come out of
it very much condemn these u.s. strikes
it seems to be standing very strongly
with the PMF and it has not really
condemned the rocket attacks against
places where US you know our base for it
very much things that the government
will not take a strong stance against
these rocket attacks it will stand with
the PMF and it remains to be seen
whether this will result in an actual
formal effort to table a bill to excel
for into something only the government
can be Parliament cannot initiate
legislation
to excel foreign troops who will be
watching whether the Prime Minister's
office which is of course in a caretaker
role after other abdelbaki resign will
actually support such a bill and and
where do the the the Iraqi people where
do these stands with with this
precarious situation just as we're
speaking someone who were showing our
viewers pictures from just outside the
US Embassy we can see their significant
numbers of people slightly earlier we're
gathering outside the gates of the US
Embassy now it's a mourner as we were
seeing there have been significant
amounts of protest from all sides of
Iraqi society where are the Iraqi people
right now when it comes to this that
this power struggle and this power play
between the alleged foreign influence in
Iraqi politics right now well that is a
very good question and it's complicated
because you certainly have parts of the
population that are more sympathetic to
the US and others because they see it as
necessary counterbalance to Iranian
influence here in the country now of
course one of the defining features of
these anti-government protests October
has been complete rejection of any
outside influence especially Iranian
influence and the question is whether
people will stand behind the PMS because
of course the US strike on Iran forces
is a foreign interference excuse me
or whether they will actually support
the US airstrikes against the Iranian
group because they see it as a way of
standing up to Iran's influence in which
they feel the government isn't doing I'm
just a reminder for our viewers who are
watching these pictures at home we are
bringing you images of the US Embassy in
Baghdad recorded just moments ago a
significant numbers of protesters have
gathered outside the US Embassy there
in the the normally heavily fortified
green zone and these protesters are
denouncing those airstrikes US
airstrikes in Iraq which had targeted
the Shia armed group Hezbollah brigades
killing at least 27 Shia fighters
simonna 14 as al Jazeera's correspondent
in baghdad semana just give us a sense
of the the atmosphere you are in the
midst of these protesters who are
gathering in the Green Zone who are
marching towards the US Embassy those
funerals have they taken place already
or are we expecting this this unrest to
continue for four sessions of cars
burying the bodies of the gate fighters
who were killed people were bidding
their goodbyes they were kissing the
trucks and basically losing the respect
now this procession is quite long I
March together with the procession from
the beginning across the hand English to
the green zone and now I'm currently
standing still in a spot about two three
hundred meters from the US Embassy and
the past 10 minutes or so there has been
a steady flow of people so this is quite
a large procession I would say at this
point we're talking about thousands of
people the atmosphere is so peaceful
people are chanting folks but there has
not been any sort of but the moment I
have not seen even any burning of flags
of course people are bearing posters
that you know cross out President Donald
Trump's face or that basically reject
the United States but so far these
people
okay so bootiful team I will leave it
there for now but thank you very much
indeed for bringing us the latest just
just so viewers are aware of what is
happening we are bringing you live
images from Baghdad's where
there are large processions taking place
large numbers of protesters have
gathered in Baghdad and as we were
hearing from Al Jazeera simonna 14 those
protesters had made their way into the
heavily fortified Green Zone and several
hundred protesters had made it to the
u.s. embassy and were protesting outside
the US Embassy we let's get more on this
now from Ahmed Rushdie he's a political
analyst and director of the House of
Iraqi expertise foundation thank you
very much indeed for joining us here on
al Jazeera would you say these protests
that we're seeing in Baghdad right now
how significant would you say these are
well actually those protesters came not
from a Cossack where they came from the
area which is near adjacent to the Green
Zone we'd show you that the the the
military forces the security forces
they'll help them to enter the glued-on
to make the protesters to make them
actually reach the American Embassy of
course there are more supporters called
the Qataris mullah who are which are
attacked yesterday by the American
forces by the American airplanes and it
should it should stay there for about
one hour and then it should be dissolved
they will not stay there in between Iran
they will be outside the Green Zone
after one hour but that's what they have
been told for them so how much
coordination do you think there is with
the Iraqi government on this and why is
this what why is this significant I
think they take the acceptance of the
Iraqi government to do this
demonstration and they take the
acceptance of the Ministry of Interior
about this demonstration near the
American Embassy it's not adjacent or
let's say in front of the American
Embassy it's near the American Embassy
in way
because you know it's it's it's so
dangers that there will be reaching near
the American Embassy but I think it fair
it will be dissolved soon and it is it
is a signal that the Iraqi government
not accepting something happens but
what's happened yesterday anyway another
but I think by time there will be some
sort of response from other PMF forces
and they will make more demonstrations
against the American and the scene like
that what message do you think the Iraqi
governments are trying to send here to
the Americans it's supposed to be you on
you are in the Iraqi soil so you're
supposed to be not marginalized the
Iraqi government and what actually the
Americans told so many times the Prime
Minister that where we have been
attacked so many times I'm you should do
something probably you know the desire
the design prime minister actually that
cannot help anywhere another to
stabilize the situation between Qatar
has behind the American forces in in
Iraq so I would also it's a message is
that we are eager to have some sort of
respond a strong respond against any
attacks it will happen in the future
against any troops from the PMF or from
the Iraqi forces that it's supposed to
be claimed they attacked American forces
well this is coming at a time of
significant upheaval in Iraq the Iraqi
government is dealing with large numbers
of protests from Iraqi civilians who are
unhappy at the the level of interference
as they put said in Iraq domestic
affairs how do you think this impacts
the situation as it stands how do you
think the Iraqi people will devolve you
these protests which are taking place in
the Green Zone well well the Marius said
it clearly and obviously is that the
Iraqi government should
[Music]
any attacks that happen on any forces in
on the Iraqi soil because it's its
responsibility so what what what we are
seeing now it's it's more political
rather than to be civilian protesters or
civilian demonstrations got it show you
at the end it's it's it's getting more
and more more advanced for the bad
relationship between the Iraq and the
and the u.s. especially the Iraqi
government and I think by time we're
gonna lose the support of the whole
international community so it needs to
be managed well I mean the relationship
between the Iraqi government and the US
in the air another because we all know
that we already have - we already have
so many security problems and we have
already also so many financial problems
so I think by time either the Iraqi
government going to control these
demonstrations and will not accept any
more or the Iraqi government will solve
the problem of attacking their American
forces in the on the Iraqi soil so it
still it is the responsibility of the
Iraqi government well it since the Iraqi
government is in a rather difficult
position here because it doesn't want
the Americans to be carrying out attacks
on its soil without its consent but it
also has a significant chunk of the
population who are very unhappy with
groups who appear to be allied with Iran
so which way do you think the Iraqi
government is leaning is it going to
lean eventually towards groups who are
more favorable to Iran is it going to
lean more towards the US are ultimately
Kurds at lean more towards the
population in Iraq who have been
protesting solidly for weeks if not
months now
well I think and that's why we are in
the middle of multiple crises because
the Iraqi government does not have a
real decision about to whom should the
the government leaned on to the Iraqi
people to the Iranian to the Americans
no one knows what's happening they are
all that's why they are sneer to be
corrupted and that's why we need to be
dysfunction and I think it will be what
happens those two three days it will
accelerate the acceptance of a candidate
that have some sort of a balance as a
prime minister had some sort of a
balance between the state and the and
between Washington and Tehran on the
Iraqi soil we need someone like that